so fox news shared a just obviously  photoshopped image of the judge who  authorized the search warrant on trump's  mar-a-lago  and it's just so obvious that this is  fake that it's actually shocking that  they even did this and with a completely  straight face they did it um humiliating  not surprising and of course the  narrative with fox and right wing media  about this third search warrant was  the same from day one which was the  search warrant was immoral unethical  biased and maybe even illegal the  reality is it was none of those things  uh authorized by merrick garland  authorized by christopher wray the fbi  director chosen by trump signed off on  by a judge probable cause affidavits  everything was there these people are  pathetic